hi everyone i just did an amazing
interview with carlo revelli
the man is like stephen hawking plus
albert einstein reincarnated
and uh he's so fascinating such a
uh such a european such an italian and
such an inspiration to me as an
experimentalist that i can have high
level conversations
talk about experiment talk about
philosophy talk about poetry
talk about our influences and and in
human nature
and to me these kinds of interviews is
what make doing the into the impossible
podcast all worth it
you're going to learn about his new kind
of perspectives
on theories of everything on quantum
gravity
on working with benedict cumberbatch how
would you like to have
your audiobook read by benedict
cumberbatch which he did
and uh and just just be delighted by
this
incredible character who's tremendously
inventive creative and is not afraid of
controversy and
i press him as i do with all my guests
no one gets a free pass on the end of
the impossible podcast
but nevertheless you're going to enjoy
this interview as much as i did
please do those following things if
you're on
listening to this on itunes please
subscribe please leave a rating if
you're on spotify
etc do a follow um youtube do the same
please do so it keeps the show going
gets me great guest access
like today and you'll hear about an
upcoming project that i hope to involve
carla with
that involves el maestro galileo
and you'll hear about that and much much
more and get tuned up
teed up and ready for his upcoming book
which is coming out
this spring summer depending on where
you are
and we will have carlo back he had such
a good time he's coming back on
thank you very much now enjoy this blast
of a voyage into the impossible
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from
magic
for everything there is a season and a
time
for every purpose under heaven a time to
be born a time to die
a time to plant a time to pluck up that
which was planted
a time to kill time to heal a time to
break down
and a time to build up a time to weep
and a time to laugh a time to mourn
and a time to dance a time to cast away
stones and a time to gather stones
together a time to embrace
and a time to refrain from embracing
time to seek and a time to lose a time
to keep and a time to cast away
a time to rend a time to sow
a time to keep silence and a time to
speak
a time to love and a time to hate a time
for war
and a time for peace today we're talking
with the incomparable
carlo rivelli master of time master of
the order of time
carlo this that i just read you was
written
it's called hell it's a
i believe it is too and i actually
quoted from it in my book
um uh losing the nobel prize but also in
my thesis
the opening chapter was better is the
end of a thing
than the beginning thereof i want to ask
you do you think that cohes
uh influenced the following two people
uh isaac newton who said
for every action there is an equal and
opposite reaction
and uh and or arthur c clarke the
namesake of this
uh fine institution that i am the
co-director of at uc san diego who said
for every
expert there's an equal and opposite
expert did kohelet did ecclesiastes
influence these two
great minds i don't know
certainly not but it certainly
influenced a lot of
thinkers all through humankind
indeed so today we're talking about a
lot of things including
emergence of perhaps space-time itself
but before we get there with one of the
really the guiding lights of modern not
only modern
uh physics and fundamental theories but
also of
the popularization and the entrancement
if such a concept exists with uh human
beings all over the world
with his popular writing and even his
appearances in
such vast and diverse projects as disney
movies as i
learned that you were in a disney movie
is that right
i was a disney character it was
disneyland disney
zayads i don't know if there's a verb of
that so there's a there's a little
carlo character there with a disney face
if i was in a disney you know movie
would be pinocchio because i uh
i think well careful pinocchio is the
only italian book that has been
translated more
than than my seven brief lessons in
physics
which i know has been translated right
now it's being translated into the 42nd
43rd
24th 24th yeah wow unbelievable well i
want to talk to you and this is uh this
is something i'm springing on you
without any notice i'm sorry but
but i am involved in a project to
translate this not to translate this
book this is the dialogue
concerning two chief world systems it
was written by a fellow italian who knew
a thing or two about time
uh that's perhaps one of your great
influences galileo
el maestro the galileo galilei of course
and it turns out carlo that this book
has been translated obviously many many
times
uh it has been even published in an
ebook which is hard to find but it does
exist
but no such audiobook of this exists
so what i'm going to propose to you if
you're willing after this interview
uh is to help me with an italian
colleague of mine
just record the forward in galileo's
voice we are making the first authorized
edition courtesy of the publisher of the
estate of
uh that that owns the rights to this
book not galileo but the university of
california owns this particular
translation so anyway
i'm going to ask you to read the voice
of galileo when the time comes not today
it's a great honor i mean of course
galileo is a it's it's a myth for
for everybody doing science but he's not
just that
one of the fathers of science science
has many fathers but one of the great
fathers of science
but he's also an incredible writer and
it's an inspiration for
anybody who want to write about science
he was writing to to
in a way that everybody at his time
could read his books
that's right and i i um actually quoted
from that
uh in a piece i'm doing a series just
kind of on a physicist take on the
dialogue and i noted that he came up not
only with concepts in physics carlo as
you know
but also concepts in psychology for
example there's one effect called the
dunning-kruger effect
which basically i exhibit which is that
you think you know a little bit
and so because you know a little bit you
think you know everything so
galileo says this he says this vain
presumption of
understanding everything can have no
other basis
than never understanding anything for
anything
for anyone who had experienced just once
the perfect
understanding of one single thing and
had truly tasted
how knowledge is accomplished would
recognize that of the infinity of truths
he understands nothing i mean how
beautiful is that
how how to how to how to resonates that
what newton says at the end of his life
right that he's like a child
in front of the of the ocean of our
ignorance and you know what
in the in my popular books i've noticed
something
the people who love my books more are
those who know nothing about science or
those who know deeply about science i
mean the scientists
uh the people who know something about
science that tend to
like my books less because they think
they know already
that's very interesting i think it is a
manifestation of this i i actually
learned
a great deal not only um you know how to
frame things in a way that was
influential on me from your writing on
my own popular science writing
but also uh understanding new concepts
and just the
the essence of a concept i mean let's
get to
uh let's get to the order of time we'll
get that out of the way then we'll get
to some
we're gonna take a deep dive my audience
is incredibly astute we had on this
summer lee smallin you might have seen
uh sabina haasenfelder eric weinstein
max tag mark
stefan alexander and uh and also james
beacham
we went over this over a million people
saw our conversations about theories of
everything
i'm going to talk to you about a
provocative new idea i have for an
experiment of everything
uh but before we get there i want to
talk about the order of time because it
is such a lovely book
and it really crystallizes in my mind i
i listened i read it and i listened to
the audiobook
read by none other than uh benedict
cumberbatch
i think we i like his name because it
has cmb in it and that's very
[Laughter]
uh he has a great voice uh although he
does make a typo
did i really write this it's so
beautiful
well though one of my kids caught a typo
that i'm sure that you didn't make but i
think he did he
he calls the process that produces
helium from hydrogen in the sun he calls
it fission
oh no no it was my mistake what a
mistake i'm totally stupid yeah yeah i'm
totally stupid but
when i did catch it i said oh come on
you know how can i do i confuse fusion
with vision which is makes no sense at
all i mean a physicist shouldn't do this
especially an italian physicist
especially in italian but but i did
sorry
i mean it's corrected in the new
editions of course uh as soon as i saw
it but it was my
my being idiot good to know well anyway
it doesn't detract from the enjoyment of
that wonderful book
so in that book you really if i could
summarize it it's it's really you know
an ode to classy us et cetera but but
why did you
um why did you come upon this as an idea
worthy of your time you have an
incredibly
demanding schedule uh with this you're
so generous with your time but it took
me a long time to set it up because
you're so busy
traveling doing research how do you
decide that a topic is worthy of carlo
rivelli's time
that is the most that is the most
precious commodity some
say i actually disagree with that and
that'll be my next question but how do
you find the time
well it's a it's a it's hard you know i
i wrote a book to explain that time is
uh is different than what we think about
but in reality now in our life lifetime
is this uh
this is this difficult thing to we have
to juggle with
but you know the the the big mystery
about time the big problem about time i
think
everybody's puzzled and confused because
it's not one
it's a it's it's many layered problems
the problem about time so everybody
talks about some different aspects of
time
and my book um i try to disentangle the
various pieces
so i think we make a mistake when we we
say time is this
or time is in fundamental physics size
is not in fundamental physics time
emerging this way time to measure that
way
that's a mistake um time is a time of
our experience
it's a very the notion
layered it has a direction it has memory
it has a metric it has a lot of
properties that we bundle together
in a single notion of time but in in
nature
they come from different parts of nature
uh
from thermodynamics from the newtonian
approximation
from disregarding quantum gravity effect
from our brain
because we remember the past so the book
tries to uh separate this different
aspect of time
and i think then it's it's much more
clear
what this complex and mysterious things
um that heim is
actually emerges from the complexity of
the natural world
yeah i recently reread a brief history
of time stephen hawking's magnum opus
and in addition that came out just a
year or two before he died the third or
fourth edition
and i had never really appreciated when
i read it when i was 16 i couldn't
really understand it
and it was very uh it was beyond my
appreciation and now
i come to it with the sophistication of
a practicing physicist a professor of 17
years
um at uc calif uh san diego and and the
comments that i would make on it is was
really startling in that
it's really a book about god and and
his feelings about god which is which
startled and shocked me because
he was known of course as a devout
practicing atheist
most of his life he wrote many many uh
works on that but actually the last word
of his book
is about god and it's like we would know
the mind of god and he was always kind
of mischievous
as you know and you knew him uh of
course but but that his
his main purpose in that book was to
present these different arguments
thermodynamic time
psychological time biological time and
then the notion of time in physics
and i feel that he felt victim to the
very same thing
that um our friend the maestro galileo
fell
victim to which is what we call
confirmation bias i'm certainly
used to this as well but in the book
it's really a polemic
about the no boundary proposal in that
he's he's trying in the 1980s to justify
why the no boundary proposal
is the right notion of how perhaps
the origin of time itself emerges i
guess you can be more
uh precise with your definition but how
time came about
um basically cleaving off from this
abstract notion of space-time
uh becoming time itself and that he
viewed that
as an invalidation of the two main
reasons to have god
in other words god was necessary to
create time and god was necessary to
create the universal laws of nature
we'll get into that in a bit but
to honking he could get rid of both of
those and therefore there'd be no need
in physics for god i wonder why do you
think
um you know religion and and and
theology why do you think it's so
impo so important to hawking who was an
atheist
in that you know he he wrote one book
called a brief history of time to
obviate the need for a god to create
time
but also he wrote a second another book
the grand design to establish that m
theory gives the laws of nature i assume
you don't agree with that
but i don't yeah let me give your take
first on the no boundary proposal
uh do physicists take this seriously
mike my belief is that they do not
as a justification of how time itself
began what do you think
oh i think they do really i mean not not
as a solved problem
but as one of the possible hypotheses
not the only one
if you use loop quantum gravity and you
you study the same
problem namely what happened at the big
bang essentially
so we we you know very well much better
than me we understand the history of our
universe
uh pretty well for 13 14 billion years
in the past but then we don't know
what came before uh and what came before
requires quantum gravity and quantum
gravity
has been my the job of my life of course
uh
so uh to to understand what would come
before we need a
quantum c of gravity and like loop
control it is one
and and hawking had a a a
a tentative theory of quantum gravity um
his euclidean quantum gravity so he
tried to use it to see what happened
and and he came up with jim hartle of
course with this idea that
in fact you don't need time to exist
before the big bang
it's a perfectly valuable idea i think
it's
as logical as possible as a possibility
is
is that the only possibility no in fact
loop control gravity
seems to suggest something else if you
write equations
sort of the quantum gravitational
equation and you run back on time
what you find is a big bang it just you
can continue easily and
you find a previous contracting universe
a big bounce
so that's another possibility it comes
out from low control gravity comes
out also out from other ideas
we just don't know um i think
we are gonna know i mean this is just a
simple
scientific problem well simple it's a
difficult scientific problem but
the kind of scientific problem that uh
humankind struggled for a while and then
solves
and it's possible that before the big
bang there was a previous phase
in fact i tend to favor it right now but
i mean i've changed mine various times
and but it's also possible that time
start what we call
time the cosmological time started there
there's nothing contradictory now
there's nothing mysterious you don't
need god for that
um in fact god has nothing to do with
that
let me tell you one thing there was a
beautiful conversation between uh the
guy who
first started thinking about this
question which is la mer
yeah the metro in french means
maestro the the master
but he was a very humble and marvelous
scientist one of great scientists and
he's the one who realized that ice and
theory really predicts a big bang and
something quantum must have happened
there and iraq
everybody knows iraq dirac was an artist
um le metro was a
catholic priest so obviously um
a religious person and and a believer in
in in
a god who create the two things being
different but he was both
um and there's a beautiful conversation
that is uh it's it's reported by iraq
himself in a in a in a
collect in a recollection of his
conversation with with lemaitre
which iraq sort of trying to being kind
you know iraq was a was was borderline
autistic it was not very good in social
relations but
trying to be kind to lemaitre says well
you did this great
things in cosmology it should be very
close to your
you know religious um
cosmology is uh is is the closest thing
to religion and uh
le met the the priest the catholic the
greatest cosmologist of
of of the early times of cosmology
answer not at all
yeah astral cosmology and religion have
nothing to do with one another
and then um uh the iraq as a surprise
and says so
why do you say that is there other
sciences which are closer to religion
and uh le met the catholic answers
psychology okay and he's believer
and i think it's totally right i'm not a
believer i'm an atheist i'm a serene
happy
without any doubt to artists but i think
it's he's right
religion is not a bunch of stupid ideas
at all
it's an intense experience that people
have it's a way of looking at the world
but if you have if you want to
understand what it has
if you want to understand it in
scientific terms which is possible you
have to look
in your brain how we work how we think
how we conceptualize
has nothing to do with what happened 30
billion years ago that's a scientific
question yeah when i um when i
uh read for the first time that
lemaitre's ideas were
first tried to be used by the pope at
that time to bolster
to bolster the you know the the creation
genesis
that's true it's a fantastic story i
mean the pope this is a papayas
i forgot um he gave some speeches
saying oh the the cosmologists have
proving
god because it's a big bang this
confirms the genesis
and and and uh lemaitre uh who's a much
more interesting
intelligent person run to rome and and
and tried to
to talk the pope out of that and he
succeeded
in fact his point was let's not confuse
things this is nothing to do with uh
i mean the history of the universe has
nothing to do with god i mean the the
if there is anything interesting in the
genesis this has to do with uh
with uh with a personal experience of
people with what happened inside people
not not the history of the world and and
in fact he convinced the catholic church
it's remarkable because other christian
denominations
nowadays still try to connect
uh cosmology with with theology i think
it's totally idiot
i mean uh we the the the bible has
absolutely nothing to do
um with what we know about the united
i read st i'm a practicing jew i'm not
orthodox you know fundamentalist but i
am a practicing jew
and i you know i don't work on the
sabbath i take time
and you're right the the most meaningful
thing even from a religious point of
view
people should note that the there are 35
verses
in the torah in the old testament as we
we call it the torah
um that involve plausibly some version
of creation or
creation of animals or people so 35
verses out of 35
000 verses so it's point one percent of
the entire book
is could be considered about the
creation of you and i always say like
imagine you picked up a book
and it was like the title of the book
was like great
football players of of 1975 and it's a
thousand pages long
and there's only one page about football
players and the rest it's about you know
like uh the vietnam war and you'd be
like this book is not
it's not an accurate it's like the
people misconstrue
the notion of wisdom and knowledge and
that sciences
means and you can correct me i'm sure
you know latin much better than i do but
science means knowledge not wisdom
and i think they're different things and
i think there's an attempt to
reconcile and combine wisdom and
knowledge from pure scientific
fact and i don't i think that's a
misapplication and and one thing that
speaks
i don't think it's a misapplication i
think that we should not
break uh our knowledge and our wisdom in
pieces
uh i think we should keep them together
uh i i don't think there are
different different levels of our think
in the world i think
that that's a mistake uh we learn things
from science
uh science it's a it's a great tool
of course uh i mean we're humans with
humans concerns there are a lot of
things about
ourselves that we don't understand um
if we but what we shouldn't the mistake
it's
it's to uh to mix different parts
of our knowledge i think that our
how would you say spiritual or whatever
uh our world view
should be deeply informed by science we
change because of science because we
learn
i mean when we learn darvin when we
learn copernicus
when we learn einstein or quantum
mechanics we change our view of the
world
and i try to talk about my in my books
about all that
um and this changes our view of
ourselves also i don't believe in the
ancient wisdom at all
i don't think that we find great wisdom
in old books
because all books are all books what
what what's good about all books is that
a lot of people have been
talking about them over and over so we
don't read the book we read the
the stratification of commentaries and
if you are if
you read the torah you know what i mean
um
and that's interesting but it's also a
lot of you know
going back to wrong ideas so
i think that
we can science is complex and but
science can include the science of you
ourselves yes and it can include
understanding our values our emotions
our yes
and our sense of why we live and and and
namely what we want from ourselves or
what we fear
uh we shouldn't separate wisdom and
science
of course we should separate what we
want in life
from the cosmology of the big bang these
are two different stories
this is a it's like you know it's my
uh my foreigners broken that's a problem
uh it's my girlfriend happy that's a
totally different problem i mean this is
a it's a
you should i should mix these two
problems but there's a you but we are
the same
and and in my in my science
in my philosophy my life i try to bring
things together
i i work in loop quantum gravity i it's
a very specific problem
it brings to a rethinking of space every
thinking of time
i want this rethinking to stay together
with the way i think about myself
i see that in your writing it's it is
not just
uh in its prose which is poetic and
beautiful
uh but that is sort of a vector a
delivery mechanism you know we're in
this
age of viruses and so forth but you you
can infect
in a good way the reader with beautiful
prose for he or she may not understand
the depths of the science
and actually you give them opportunities
to skip ahead skip back
as is necessary but i guess you know the
fundamental thing for me is
is that there is sort of a halo effect
you know for example
einstein uh was was asked to be the you
know the second prime minister
of israel now the man had very very
baroque uh notions about nationalism and
so forth
and you know because he knew a lot about
brownian motion and he knew a lot about
the photoelectric effect and gravity and
time uh but you and i both know he had
you know seven
major discoveries each worthy of a nobel
prize yeah and he had seven major
blunders each worthy of an ignoble prize
in some sense oh i
yes yes yes i wrote i wrote i wrote a
paper on the list of mistakes of
einstein oh really i want to link to
that afterwards
oh yeah yeah yeah i i i could say more
than that i think einstein is not
one of the i mean maybe the without
maybe
uh the scientists who have got more
right things in his life
at least i mean after newton um
but he's also of all the scientists i
know the one who has more mistakes
like babe ruth i mean mathematical
mistakes are conceptual mistakes
assumptions which are wrong mistakes
that he himself recognized he changed
his mind various times back and forth
um some he corrected some know
you know what i think the two things go
together yeah it's a sign of
intelligence
changing your mind so i tell my string
theory friends you know change change
your mind it's a science of intelligence
yeah i always ask the question you know
before i debate with somebody as galileo
does in this great book this book is a
book about debates it's a debate between
uh three people whose names you can
pronounce better than my simplicio
salviati and sagredo and fantastic you
know i also wrote a a a debate
with the same characters oh you did oh
you must give it to me
so now you're basically agreeing to be a
part of this project to translate
galileo
in audio form imagine that imagine
benedict cumberbatch reading
you know simplicio i don't know we'll
get we'll get some ideas from you carlo
but but i think you're right and
in america i don't know if you're
familiar from your time spent here but
we have
you know famous baseball heroes and one
of whom was babe ruth
who was one of the greatest players of
all time he could pitch the ball
you know incredibly fast he could hit
more home runs but he struck out
more than any other player but he also
hit more home runs than any other player
and he's sort of you know
the einstein of of baseball i suppose
you could say
but you know it kind of brings me back
to what you said about lemaitre i mean
this guy is remarkable to mature because
he resisted
the insults the daggers the barbs of
einstein who called his misapplication
of gr atrocious despicable you know
einstein was brutal to him and the
maitre was just this happy kind of
cherub
and he was just like and let me tell you
my view by a few of the
so he went to the pope and said oh pope
you are wrong
in trying to connect the the the genesis
of the big bang
and he actually convinced the pope right
the pop
follower and and and and he went to
einstein
when when eisen as you said was was uh
and said einstein you were wrong
and lemaitre was right i mean in the 30s
after
after hubble and and and so on einstein
changes this idea so i mean it's not
it's not a thing of nothing of you know
the same person going to the pope and
and finding it wrong and pop agreeing
and going to einstein and finding wrong
nice and agreeing it's quite a
achievement
and not only that the most fun fun
the most wonderful things about lemaitre
is is how humble
he was you know in in the paper i mean
all the credit
about the expansion universe nowadays
goes to um
to hubble uh which of course has has a
huge is
played a huge a huge game but uh
the the paper by uh by lemay
has already uh the idea has already the
analysis of the first
observation of the redshift of the
nebulae before a humble measurement
and has already the humble law
essentially but then something credible
happened
when this paper was translated in
english much later
because uh because it was not in the
english literature he he
put it in an obscure little journal
he himself took away the part
that made clear that the
he was the one first one to read the
data correctly
because he said well hubble that are so
much better than mine that is no point
in
so you see he he didn't care he he cared
about truth
yeah not about his own personality and
this is wonderful
i wish scientists would be like that
today yeah i know
some that are like that some not at all
like that
let's get into that because i i find it
very interesting i get emails
every day and and some people are
listening to this podcast you know
friends of mine that will be listening
to this
watching this on youtube and listening
to this on the podcast forum
and they'll send me their theories of
everything and they're very earnest and
they'll usually say things like
professor keating
i'm sure you get these carlo einstein
was wrong you know i
i know that there's a theory of quantum
gravity uh that he failed to do
uh but i'm not good at math um so if you
help me do it i'll split the nobel
prize proceeds i'll never sprint the
medal with me
but uh but and i claim in my book that
that's a form of modern-day idol worship
in the sense that
people worship the nobel prize and in
fact refer to it so much that it's
become sort of a secular religion but
we'll get into that some other time
anyway i get these comments but i never
get comments boltzmann was wrong
clausius was wrong
why why is it that einstein is this
target
you know i think the italians say you
know the higher you fly
the easier you are to shoot down or the
revenge is the best
uh dish best serve cult i don't know but
but but tell me carla why is this
fixation with a man
why shouldn't it be with the ideas why
are we always so consumed with taking
you know einstein was wrong or i can do
what einstein didn't do
and i can do you know this or that why
not say here's an idea
it's for the universe why is it the
fixation with the man
or or the woman in some some cases
well we're humans we have our our our
weaknesses
we have our ego and all that stuff but
ideas are more are more interesting
let's talk about ideas instead of
talking about god and human and let's
think about quantum gravity and
talk about gravity i'm going to see how
human you are in this okay so i'm going
to say something by a quote again
i i don't like to venerate people just
because they have nobel prizes
but the famous richard feynman said the
following he said i don't care how
beautiful your theory is
how lovely the math is if it disagrees
with experiment
it's wrong and absolutely i want to ask
you
uh in the context of loop quantum
gravity there was a claim
that uh that there would be a
variability of the speed of light
depending on its energy and it's
dispersed called as dispersion
its energy it would be dependent it's
its propagation speed
effectively an index of refraction would
be color dependent
and that was a prediction loop quantum
gravity no that was a mistake
that was a a stage in which the dynamics
of lu contagio was not clear
and yet this is many many years ago so
um
at the time there was only the
hamiltonian formulation so it was much
much
harder to see to see whether uh the
quantum gravity actually implemented the
local loyalty variance which is the one
of generativity the
the symmetry of of space-time especially
activity
uh later on it became clear especially
with with the covariant formulation of
quantum gravity it's called spin form
so to find some of the geometries in
between which you can do explicitly loop
quantum gravity
it became clear that uh the theory is
locally lawyers invariant
so it doesn't break lawrence environment
so there's no preferred
reference system if you want so
then the the the claim disappeared
but that was really good because uh
because it was a they were very
very suggestions at the time and
it prompted a uh
an astrophysical research in fact a
large number of astronomical research
for violations of of fluency variants
for for
for seeing um if in fact one can
uh see a phenomenon that breaks the
symmetry of special relativity
and this was successful because nowadays
we have a lot of
bounce on on on on this effect so
nature seem to be loyalty variant
in may in many phenomena far beyond the
planck scale so this is one of the
example
in which people say there are no
experiment in quantum gravity there are
experimental quantography that's one
and in fact there were theories of
quantum gravity like all java theory and
and other theories which were trying to
build
the theory itself on the breaking of of
of lawrence in variance the planck scale
and these are largely ruled out
i mean you never really rule out
anything in sciences i mean the proper
story is a little bit uh mythical but
but they are very much in difficulty
because of this uh of these experiences
uh lupe quantum gravity on the other
hand
uh i mean its theoretical development
has been has clarified that uh the the
dynamics is lauren's environment so
there is no
there's no braking allowance environment
expected would there be
um you might be aware of a recent claim
discovery using planck
2018 data of a observation
of evidence or hint or at 2.4 sigma
which sounds uh less impressive than
99.2 percent confidence but they're the
same thing
that their universe exhibits cosmic
parity violation via
churn simon's um additional term to the
electromagnetic lagrangian this is by
ichiro kamatsu
who's a friend and colleague and his uh
and his colleague
who's also a colleague miyamori who
works on the polar bear experiment with
me
and uh and my team but uh they claim
that the uh photons cosmic polarization
photons rotate as they
travel from the last scattering surface
to the earth and it made me think of a
potential probe that i want to pitch to
the ravelli funding agency
which would be looking for parity
violating signatures or maybe even maybe
less
less baroque than that just looking for
a time of flight difference
between vertical polarization of
distance
sources and horizontal polarized light
and their propagation and when we see
them
from a gamma-ray burst or from a
supernova it's actually not well known
i've had conversations with with some of
the top
supernova physicists robert kirschner my
late colleague andy friedman here
about testing uh lorentz invariance
violation and parity violation
using time of arrival from supernova of
vertical and horizontal polarization
is there any test analogous to the speed
of light for
for red and blue photons for example is
there any test
like i'm proposing that could have some
discriminating power for uh lqg
i'm not aware of anything specific in
that in the literature
uh but i wouldn't exclude that like i
mean
if you nowadays if you tell me about
lauren breaking lawrence invariants
um i uh you know everything is possible
but but that's not
everything possible is interesting but
uh parity or chirality
uh in in in nature i mean we know that
nature is karel and we know that
nature treats left and right differently
and in
in if you remember loop quantum gravity
was both
the the action of loop quantum gravity
is not exactly the
the generativity action there's another
term that has no effect
in in the classical theory but as an
effective quantum theory is called the
holster
with a parameter which goes on the name
of the very immediate parameter
um which has the opposite the opposite
uh
uh parity if you want as a as an epsilon
inside
um and and the all the the the the the
was born on a formalism that treats
um the the the two opposite
chiralities differently so
i wouldn't be surprised if something
uh could happen i mean i i think it's a
very interesting direction to explore
it has not been explored sufficient
there are some pa some papers but i
don't think it has exploited
very much in the in the literature
remember smalling
and um what's his name juan
yeah uh they were trying to explore
something in that direction
uh they were excited at some point um
but uh but
but uh do we understand loop control
gravity today loop quantum gravity is a
very
that we understand it it's a very
i would say it's not a theory of
everything it's not a grand used thing
but it's very well defined i mean it has
very clear hypospace very clear
evolution equations so uh it's a it's a
theory of quantum gravity we don't know
if it is right
because until we make
a successful prediction we cannot say
this is right but i think it proves that
bacteria quantum gravity can be written
and is there it's finite and ultraviolet
divergences
um and in it the way it is
i don't see it uh
character breaking this effect that your
your chirality i mean
this effect that you're saying but i
wouldn't exclude that
it might come in exactly because there's
this uh
other um this other term
which isn't a possible signature yeah
when i uh i want to get to
possible tests under the strong
gravitational regime of colliding black
holes in a minute but
before we get there um i want to take
one step back for the audience who
may be getting a little bit lost but but
uh but probably not because they're very
astute
we've had on frank wilcheck juan
maldasena martin reese we've had on
the top luminaries in this field and i
always ask them and sir roger penrose
has been on four times including one
after he won his nobel prize and i asked
him at that time
in con in conversation with um with him
about uh about black holes and here's
the following thing let me run this by
you
i feel like uh the the the
quantum gravity argument is sort of this
ouroboros the snake that eats its tail
it's almost like a tautology
in that we say we need a quantum theory
of gravity to understand
the properties of black holes within
their event horizons near singularities
and strong gravitational fields
we also say we need it at the to explain
the origin of time if indeed time had an
origin
in a quantum sense in a big bang in
inflation something like this we need
to have now both of those as hawking
himself proved for both of those fields
we are fundamentally firewalled off we
can never observe
a singularity we don't believe there are
naked singularities we don't believe we
can observe
what's inside of an event horizon and
get that information out so it's sort of
firewalled off
conversely the beginning of the universe
when time as you point out how does time
pass when
time comes into existence in a certain
sense so
we may and hawking showed that there
would be this singularity
um along with penrose who and i asked
this of roger and i said
so there are these two scenarios we say
we need quantum gravity and yet we can't
observe quantum gravitational effects
um what do you say is this a tautology
is there any other reason that we
believe we must have a quantum theory of
gravity i mean who says
that we have a quantum theory of gravity
why do we need it
no i disagree i disagree entirely and
black holes are a good example
um because uh
let me tell you what uh loop quantum
gravity
uh predicts about black holes uh this is
in fact
the main sort of hard science in which
i'm working right now
uh i last night last night it was i was
up until very late
trying to to do and not succeeding to do
a calculation exactly
time in order i have to get the order of
time right
right is uh that that book should have
been
um titled the disorder of time but
anyway that's a different story
um so uh
what if if you take the the question of
lukewarm this has been done in a number
of different ways i mean different
group quantified formalism so it seemed
to be pretty
pretty pretty solid as a prediction of
ultimate gravity
if you fall into a black hole um you you
have the questions you see what happened
the you you go toward the center at the
center you see the
the curvature increases so you enter the
quantum gravity regime you do the
calculation
and you discover that you continue in a
region
which is which has a geometry not of the
inside of a black hole but inside of the
white hole
so it's which is a well-known solution
of ison equations
as well and if you look at the the thing
from the outside the black hole for the
outside
what you see is that uh um there is
hockey radiation so it becomes smaller
smaller smaller smaller some point is
very small so this is
there is a horizon and then when it's
sufficiently small is a quantum
transition a tunneling effect
that transform it uh from a black hole
horizon to a white whole horizon
and and this is compatible with with
einstein classicalized and theories
uh equations outside so um therefore now
you have a white hole you've gone
through this quantum phases the
tunneling
like like the standard quantum tunneling
you know a particle that goes through a
potential wall is the same phenomenon
so the black holes become a white hole
so whatever is inside comes out
and easily comes out in fact it has two
comes out because it is it is a white
hole
now uh i was sure that this is what
nature has decided uh well
no of course because we're not sure that
luke quantum gravity is correct but
that's a scenario it's a possible
scenario and
in fact i think it's a reasonable
scenario i think that the idea that
people have
that the end of the black hole
evaporation a white hole
a black hole pop disappears into nothing
it's silly
there's no theory that says it is
appearing to nothing what it does is
is to uh to to tunnel into a white hole
and and inside uh you see a small
old black hole which is a teeny tiny
mouth tinny horizon but in size huge is
a huge huge thing inside so you don't
disappear into nothing
it it it does it passes a quantum region
and then it comes out
from from the small mouth so therefore
um the we do see the quantum gravity
region of course we do see the quantum
gravity region is whatever comes out
and there is no reason whatsoever for
thinking
that is hidden um
in other words the horizons
exist um you know hawkins once
wrote a paper saying there are no black
holes
uh it's sort of bhutad but i think it's
it's a uh
he was playing on the definition of
black hole if you define a black hole as
an event horizon yes
then i don't think there are black holes
because an event horizon is horizon
survives all the way to infinity
but horizon don't survive all the way to
infinity there is nothing forever in
life
quantum mechanics changes thing so the
the rise of the black hole
real black holes you see in the sky it's
a trapping horizon
the the correct notion that roger pen
will also got the nobel prize for this
introduced so it's a horizon you cannot
come out from there
but it's not something that lasts
forever because it's quantum
gravity right right so when it becomes
small becomes
a white hole and if you want a white
hole
has a singularity in the past the black
hole is singularity in the future
but singularities are just what happen
when you enter in a quantum gravity
region in in generativity
so you enter into this quantum where
there is no singularity singularity is
just you know
the theory not being able to to continue
because something else coming in and we
know what comes in it's quantum
mechanics
so the black hole singularity uh it's
actually a quantum transition to a white
hole singularity which is just
whatever comes out and then you see what
comes out
so um the argument
is hidden behind a um
inventorizer i think it's wrong
so that we won't right so that it is
possible now are there
ways as you know probably sabina hassan
feldman and others who's been a guest on
the show
she claims that this you know the
hawking well the information lost
paradox which would be
leading to the resulting emission of
hawking radiation or concomitant
reorganization perhaps destruction of it
i've had john prescott
as well she calls it one of the greatest
hypes in all of science
you know that this is not really a
paradox and in any case it's unavoidable
unobservable because we you know hawking
radiation it won't occur
for you know mo you know millennia to
the millennium's power
so how do we how do we go about again
you know adhering to feynman i asked
this of john prescott if you're saying
you know hawking radiation
you know you you won this bet okay but
do you really know if you won this bet
because we we won't actually be around
to witness these types of phenomena so
feynman and by the way how do you know
well you know that will witness hawking
radiation i mean the time scales are you
know
for for a large enough black hole or are
you know long how you know there aren't
small black holes
well we don't have any uh currently
don't have any evidence i don't know for
sure that we don't have we didn't have
evidence of black holes big black holes
20 years ago it doesn't mean that they
didn't didn't mean that they didn't yeah
i'm not saying that they don't exist i'm
saying
the uh this is a wild speculation it's
just a solution of ice and equation i
mean it is a
they could very well be there in fact
there is a lot of work
on the possibility that you know small
black holes were produced in the in the
early universe they promoted university
you should be a will
yeah i'm sure you know about that right
yeah the closer to your job than mine
yeah
yeah no it's certainly we we are and we
and we think about that so it may very
well be that there are small black holes
in the early universe which were
produced
we don't know because it's a tricky
complicated story calculation depend on
many details
but it's very plausible and i think look
when when i was a student i started on
steven weinberg fantastic book of
generativity which essentially says
uh come on black holes don't exist in in
reality
it's very unlikely that they exist it
talks about the steady state theory too
yeah it's interesting no no i mean
here's a chapter on
on on the mathematics it's a completely
clear completely
then he says look to make a black hole
you should squeeze the earth in a
centimeter cube
come on this is not going to happen in
in the nature but nature is more
creative than
even the stephen bible who's the great
scientist
and in fact in those years the the first
indication of black hole severe
were coming out right the 70s the 72 73
when it's sinus
um and now we we are totally sure that
things
in the sky exist which are well um
described by
uh the mathematics of generativity of
black holes
um but we first find the stellar ones
and then to our surprise we said that
they were the galactic one which in fact
we were receiving signals by by decades
and we didn't know what they were
and then we found out billions of solar
times and then we find intermediate ones
i mean
we are discovering new kinds of black
holes every day so um
i think it's perfectly plausible that
there are black holes um
i don't know but but it's perfectly
plausible that there are black holes um
uh producing the
universe or even if there was a bounce
instead of a big bang from from previous
phases of the universe black hole can
easily go through the bounds
and so that's how those
although in that case i did falsify that
to him i mean the the actual publication
and he and i have been over this he's a
good friend of mine
that the hawking points again i felt
were another example of confirmation
bias rearing its ugly head because
essentially what he did is take the
bicep two data
that we released and just analyze the
maps and show where regions were high
you know in apparent visual impact in
other words he looked at these maps and
said oh they must be points of high
b mode concentration and that was
totally not the way that the maps are
intended any more than an artist
conception is intended to give you a
perspective of what a black hole looks
like
but but i feel like yeah that is a
notion i want to ask you now about
gravity and
strong uh or quantum you know gravity uh
lqg in a strong gravitational field
because it seems to me
i had this conversation with lenny
suskin about a month or two ago
he believes that the you know what he
calls the stretched horizon or something
is more quantum mechanical than the
singularity in that i think it's wrong i
think he's wrong okay why
um because let me this is a this is in
fact
this same question you asked me before
about the information loss paradox
um let me be a little bit more precise
here i think
some of your audience is uh it it's well
versed in these things and we can go a
little bit in more detail
the information loss paradox um it
actually comes into
in two versions the naive one and and
the subtle one the naive one
is well thinks information falls into
black hole and then the black hole
disappears
where it is gone but that's a naive one
and the solution is very simple i mean
it will just come out later on i mean
this is
you go through a quantum gravity region
but then there is a subtle one which is
the one
which is being discussed today and is
what everybody really today calls the
the information lost paradox and this is
the idea that the paradox is not
after the end of the evaporation is
before
okay and this comes from this argument
by page
in fact then there was a cleaner version
that when a black hole becomes small
okay if you believe the pakistan idea
that the number of state of black hole
is limited by the
area of its horizon then there are
few possible state of a black hole
buckle is small now
so it can have few possible states so
therefore there is not enough room for
information inside
because you need a lot of state to hold
information okay
therefore when the black hole is is
become very small
the information that has inside should
have already come out
okay and this is what a lot of people
today believe and i am convinced that
this
is wrong because because of little
chronic gravity because
chronic gravity is no no no no not
because of contact it's a logic
it's a logic these people have been
blinded
and i think they are blinded by taking
by
overplaying holography
they fell in love with holography they
found
adf cft corresponding that somehow
seems to be connecting a boundary theory
with the internal theory so they believe
ology blindly more
than established physics and logarithmic
is not established physics is a
hypothesis
right so it's not like saying yes
maxwell equation is
quantum mechanics uh classical mechanics
this is correct within its own domain
ology is an hypothesis and it's not a
clear hypothesis it's a vague hypothesis
that it can play in different ways in
some sense it's true
for sure it's it's easy to prove
in some sense it's an hypothesis
something speculation
but now it has become a dogma okay if
you take this as a dogma that's a
mistake
then you think that all the observables
are at infinity all you can say about
the world you can say from outside so
about the black hole you imagine a black
hole something that you know is last
forever
and anything can measure it's it's on
the surface and there's little
number of degrees of freedom but you
forget one thing
and that's a key point that inside this
small surface there can be a huge volume
and all sort of possible
quantum states inside information inside
so this is a confusion between two
notions of entropy
the entropy that governs
my exchanges from the outside with these
things is a black hole
black hole is small has a small
horizon small area so it's entropy
for me it's limited
but this doesn't mean that the internal
state with room i can be entangled
can't be large and in fact it is large
just a simple just look
go into the equation believe
generativity believe quantum mechanics
believe your theory
filter it tells you that inside there's
a huge amount of information
so it's false and and is dictated by
this
falling in love with with allografy is
false
that the information comes out
before the quantum gravity regime is
false that the late hawking quanta
must necessarily be entangled with early
hawking quanta which is what people got
sort of enchanted into believing and if
you're enchanting to believe it there
you come out with all the nonsense like
the firewalls
on the on the horizon like this idea
that there is some
crazy quantum stuff on the horizon i
mean
i'm a relativist i've spent my life in
relativity there's nothing special
happening on the surface of a black hole
locally if you're in a small region it's
a completely natural
if it is special it's just your
perspective you're a sort of uh
there's a little curvature there you're
zooming to a to a
um even in a straight line which is
crazy
even when lenny calls it because he says
you know the thermal background the
stretched horizon
which is a plank length above the event
horizon apparently
um but he calls it the most quantum of
all phenomena and so it's it's surpri
i agree with you and i had juan
maldosena on the show and i asked him
specifically i said what is the value of
ads cft
it works only in five dimen we know we
don't live in five dimensions i mean
it's one of the few things we do know
and he said well the value of it is in
in part
because it teaches us about quantum
mechanics and i said
it doesn't it teaches us as an aversion
of quantum mechanics that is not the one
that might be true in our world
yeah and if this people are so crazy
about this idea why they
don't do a realistic theory instead of
doing unrealistic theories which they
know they're unrealistic theory they say
is unrealistic theory
and they say yeah but the true quantum
theory of gravity should resemble that
the day we're gonna find it
right we'll find it it might be wrong it
might be ugly it might be
spectacularly beautiful in my eyes um it
might
have incomplete pieces i'm not saying
it's a it's perfect science
far from me but there's a theory i mean
we know the question the fundamental
equation we can write them down
totally clear there's no space
fundamentals there's no time they're
quantum space
you can write the transition amplitude
in four dimensions there's no
supersymmetry
uh there is no holography in there is a
logarithm in some sense in a weak sense
there's a logarithm in fact
but it's a weak sense not in this strong
sense and it allows you to do
calculations in quantum gravity
so we do have a quantum theory of
gravity there is a quantum theory of
gravity
perhaps is wrong perhaps i'm going to
change my mind i mean say oh
this equation don't work fine we'll
change them einstein changed
the equation of generativity five or six
times before writing
that so fine i mean just i started
changing i'm gonna change everybody
should change but we have a theory which
is realistic which is
um consistent with quantum mechanics
consistent with general relativity
and there is no um
information um problem and you know
sabine um i sometimes i disagree with
her sometimes i find her she has a
strong mind a strong opinion but i think
she's
totally right that's another thing she
said she's totally on the point here
it's just hype yeah and i wonder you
know why we give into that and you
mentioned you know about why don't they
do calculations that are practical with
ads cft so i asked juan
exactly that and he said well this paper
you know that we
that he wanted to talk about is about a
humanly traversable wormhole
and so okay so that's a reasonable thing
and you know
juan of all this group is one of the
most reasonables
yes he is he is extremely and i asked
kamran
he's kind yes i i i do love his ilk
no i love one he he's he's incredibly
generous and we have uh
you know so i look for
experiments of everything i want to know
as much information
in the limited amount of time i have to
pay attention to do work to love
to do all that i wish i wish i wish i
could do more i could give you more than
that
you know to find experiments i mean my
my
my hope is to before dying to see a
confirmation of quantum gravity a
support of loop quantum gravity
something
something coming in um there's a lot of
attempts
in uh on the cmb okay try to connect the
loop contour gravity picture of the of
of the early of the promoted universe
with
cmb anomalies but it's a lot of work uh
i've not worked on that but there's a
large literature
um i am more confident in black holes
and
you know i th there have been papers
um on on signature on on um
very high energy cosmic rays uh let me
give you the the
the the the gist of the idea here if a
black hole forms
in the early universe let's say uh
after the big bang uh it traps some very
high energy photons inside uh it's small
enough
it evaporates it liberates this high
energy photon the high energy photon
flies and gets to
to us this is one of the primordial high
energy photons
if you do the calculation the spectrum
of these things
and the um the distance uh
frequency dependence is very peculiar
because of this this uh
this this this phenomenon um and this
might
leave imprints in their distribution or
stuff that's one idea
there are papers will be done i don't
know
i'm i'm waiting you probably know that
at some point faster at your burst where
there was a hope to
connect it with the i mean i don't know
how strong it is i think i'm i'm less a
believer
that this could could happen but it's
not closed and then
i have my own
favorite idea i wish i could give you
which is a dark matter how so
dark matter the best picture we have of
dark matter right now
is that it's something that interacts
only gravitationally
it's a sort of powder which has no
electromagnetic
decent interaction it's sort of flying
around
there's a little bit so density of
roughly inside the
the the the galaxy is like matter even a
little bit
more but but not concentrated in stars
um now suppose there were this
primordial black holes and they have
evaporated they become white holes
and white holes according to the the
model we have
have a very very long survival time
before before before ending because all
the thing inside should slowly
come out so white holes are little
things what what the size of a black
hole is a microgram
planck scale is a microgram what's huge
from the point of
particle physics is very small from the
point of view of your point of view it's
just a powder
and how does it interact only
gravitationally is neutral
i mean this could be a component of dark
matter do i have a way to test it
no unfortunately so every time the other
components are shoot down or
lose a loose credibility you know like
the the supersimited one
i mean is there anybody who still
believes in supersymmetry in the planet
i interviewed sheldon glashau
uh last year and i said you know in your
book cause he wrote a book called
interactions and he forecasted you know
where could physics go in the next 10
years and this was in 1988
and basically nothing had been seen you
know including proton decay
including you know signatures at the uh
super connecting super collider which
was never built but he didn't know it at
the time
and yeah so i started to ask him you
know well does this not mean that super
symmetry is ruled out
i thought he was one of the foremost
opponents of string theory and he said
no not at all and
and he seemed to be much more sanguine
about the uh you know possibility that
string theory could be manifest
but not as much as my friend and yours
cameron vapha we'll get to
why i say that later on and i take you
into the impossible with the three
questions that i ask all my guests
now take a quick break to just implore
people if you're liking this
video this conversation please leave a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
please leave a review
or follow me whatever you have to do
follow carlo
he's not super active on twitter which
explains why he's so uh so active i'll
put up his twitter
handle while he gets so much done in in
writing
in physics etc um but just to go back to
uh to the notion of testability when i
talked to lenny suskin
by the way i have on many more uh
theorists than experimentalists although
i have had on barry barish and ray weiss
speaking of black hole physics and kip
thorne has promised me he'll come on
one of these days when covet is over i
think he's just like passing me off and
but he's so productive he says he's so
productive and echoes a little what you
were saying before we started recording
you know kobe's been great in the sense
you know it's been tragic for billion
millions around the world but
but it's been good for productivity for
people like kip thorne he's like i'm not
i'm turning down every interview request
i'm working on books i'm working on
papers it's never been so productive i
should do that i should do that
i'll let you off in a couple of minutes
don't worry carlo no no no no come on
it's lovely it's it's great to talk with
you yeah so listen uh so i but i talked
to barry and i talked to
ray weiss and i said you know what are
the exciting things that you can do
with future experiments and they started
talking about yeah you could test
quantum gravity
um in particular i wonder from the
lq lqg perspective
is not a black hole the you know
colliding black hole with 30 solar
masses each
is that not the ideal laboratory in
other words when people say to me
we need the future circular collider
which is going to cost 20 billion euros
to build not to operate just
i'm not i'm not a fan of of of of
cliders uh
i mean i i don't want to make a strong
point here i don't know but
for the kind of physics i do is not
colliders we need i mean
and that's i mean look uh the the ruling
out
of some quantum theory of gravity with
the um
breaker alloys environments the planck
scale was not done by collider
you mentioned plot on the k plot of
decay was it was a great experiment
right you ruled out su5
yeah it's it's it's an effect at
a sort of the order of magnitude of the
planck energy much much higher than a
collider could even dream to get there
and it was down here a big tank of water
and some detectors around
so smashing particles is not the only
way it's a good way but it's not the
only way to test the
test nature there are other things i
mean there is cosmology is fantastic
astronomy is fantastic
gravitational wave detection is
fantastic there are a lot of things
that's what i say let me i said let me
tell you one thing because
there is an experi there is a quantum
gravity experiment
which is being much discussed now in
some corner of the community
which can be done in the lab talk about
and
i think it's extremely solid is
extremely good it's not easy to do
but it's not impossible in in a few
number of years
it's not it's not a quantitative
experiment that is going to
distinguish whether loop quantified is
true or whether string theory is true or
whatever is true but it would definitely
put
um create a superposition of geometries
in the lab and it's a fantastic
experiment
it was um um uh suggested by two groups
contempora
at the same time one in london sugar
boza and his collaborators
and uh cara marletto and blood cove
and in in oxford and it's a fantastic
idea
you take a nanoparticle you split it
into
like a stengerlak you take another one
you split it in two
and so you have four branches and in one
of these two branches
you have the two particles be very very
close
okay they're so close by that they
affect
gravitationally one another so um
there is a different phase in the
quantum evolution
in that particular branch but not in the
others
so you deface that branch and when you
bring together the two particles they
are correlated the quantum correlated so
do you
create quantum entanglement
via a very weak delicate gravitational
interaction
okay and if you do that you can prove
that this can only happen
if gravity itself namely geometry itself
is in a quantum superposition yes
so this will be in my opinion solid
uh proof i bet that the result
if the experiment can be done the
results are going to be positive yeah
solid proof
that quantum geometry exists that
geometry is not fixed
that you can put geometry in in quantum
superposition
so you see one quantum gravity
experiments
are possible i mean the the the the
astrophysical measurement of of
of of of the plant called violation of
of um
lawrence invariants this experiment in
the lab
um if you want the non-finding of
supersymmetry
at cern which threw many people in
desperation
people you know physics is in crisis
i mean the physicist is like man we're
rejoicing and we spent
years and years saying come on super
symmetry who believes that
a lot of people believe it still we've
had a lot of people believe it still but
you know a lot of people believed in
in in in in in ptolemy's system years in
the
100 years of the copernicus uh i i don't
know i mean supersymmetry might be true
it's not
it's not ruled out totally but science
doesn't
work ruling out things totally it makes
things more plausible or more
unpleasable well it's the whole
consensus is as science
proving it by by the by the number of
authors on a paper
et cetera that i i objected let me ask
you a question though because when when
bicep two
i made our announcement in 2014 yeah i
remember
i'm sorry yeah no it's okay i mean we
learned more about the universe we
learned about truth oh yeah we
did we did we did at that time lawrence
krauss and frank wilcheck
you know had come out with a paper that
said we have you know prove
quantum gravity evidence for quantum
gravity in the infliton
in the quantization of gravitational
waves and i thought that was nonsense
i actually told frank that on the show
and we didn't we didn't get into too
much detail about it because bicep two
turned out to be a non-confirmation
disconfirmed
as you know yeah i thought about that i
talked about that it's a very good
question yes
so you're you're asking me um is it
would it be if we were successful
because we had we had observed it
yes which you know the effect might
still be there
in fact we haven't observed that doesn't
mean that i still have a i have a
hundred million dollar project behind me
that's right that's right so can we say
it's it's evidence for quantum gravity
um i think i would uh
uh incline in your side uh it's a bit
stretched
yeah the experiment that you mentioned
is you know what i call quantum and i
love
your next book as has a lot to say about
this we'll talk very briefly about it
because i want to have you back if
you'll
be so generous with your time in the
future but the point is you know
what is quantum what does it mean well
people think about the double slit
experiment people think about
you know the interference the reality of
phase aharan of bomb effects
uh etc uh what do you make about these
new you know kind of conjectures
uh sean carroll has spoken a lot of your
friend sean carroll spoke a lot about
you know many worlds and and i mean
where do you come down on that
is there any impact you know because i
think ultimately what i'd love to talk
to you about today
is get a better understanding of the
role of entropy
within lq lqg in the sense that
you know what when i i'm a lay person
i'm a simple experimentalist right so
i only can remember certain bullet
points at a time and what i think about
is
space time is quantized at a certain
loop scale there's spin networks spin
foams i can understand those
i can't do the calculations but i can
understand metaphorically what
what they mean and physically what they
mean i can even think about tests as
i've already described and how we could
perhaps measure it but things like when
you talk about holography and so forth
i would have thought you would be a
proponent of it because at some level
don't you say that there is a
fundamental unit of quantum area
of volume of pixels of voxels in
lqc in lqg how does it work
uh yeah is that the most quantum
manifestation of quantum mechanics there
is space time itself
is quantized yes yes well first of all
you're not a simple experimentalist
you're a great experimentalist so
that's the main result
of loop quantum gravity not an input
it's not an assumption it's a result
um i am a you know i i
i don't believe that space and time
exists as they are
i i i i believe that uh
in a very strange theory but i'm a very
conservative uh person
i i don't believe in in a lot of
speculations i think that
um we should build on what we understand
about the world and if you take general
activity what we have understood about
general relativity namely that the space
time
the geometry of space-time is the
gravitational field it's the same thing
so we shouldn't think about space and
stuff over it
we should think of the gravitational
field and the electromagnetic field and
the dirac field and the
the young mills fields um that's one
thing we know and the other thing we
know is quantum mechanics
quantum mechanics is incredibly uh
powerful i mean it's 100 years that just
comes out right maybe one day we'll find
it wrong but it will come
i mean for the moment until we find it
wrong we we better assume
our best bet by far is assuming it's
right so if you take the two together
that's you get loop quantum weight is
just that
it's a quantum theory of generality of
space time
which is the gravitational field but the
gravitational field now is a quantum
field
so you can make measurement of the
gravitational field and
predict what you come out and in quantum
mechanics
make measurement and predict will come
out means finding the eigenvalues
of observables right that the energy of
the atom you compute the eigenvalues of
the energy
and often they come out discrete the
energy of of
of an hydrogen atom of molecule
oscillator is discrete the angular
momentum of some anything rotating is
discrete
so if you do this calculation loop
control will have it at the key
calculation loop quantum gravity
you take the the you're curious about
the geometry the geometry of anything
you have this
you know this piece of this this
notebook you won't know the area of the
surface
the area depend on the gravitational
field is something that compute
with the gravitational field which is a
quantum field so the area of this is a
it's a quantum observable
space time is quantum that's the point
you do the calculation and you find
discrete eigenvalues so you find that
the area cannot be arbitrary small
it sits on either zero or it's weighted
a planck size area which you can compute
or the next one or the next one the
discrete
so this makes space-time not continuous
but discrete because the you cannot zoom
arbitrary
small there is no arbitrary small it
doesn't exist in nature
and you have this quantum space it's
elementary grain of space the volume
also
is quantized so you have discrete you
have
chunks of volume which can be this big
this big this big but not arbitrary
small
okay and and you have to think about the
quantum
possible quantum states of space-time as
this quantile space
so to connect it to one another that the
picture was being uh speed networks
that with with transition amplitude from
one another they don't
sit in a space they are space it's
the space is made by these things here
and this is what explains
why um loop quantum gravity cures
the ultraviolet divergences because
ultraviolet divisions they all come from
the hypothesis that you use in
perturbation theory
that space is continuous all the way
down you have arbitrary high frequency
uh in the theory but there are no
arbitrary high frequencies when you get
to the planck that's it but careful
and now i come to your to your point
space is quantum so it's not discrete in
the sense
in which uh you know you take a set of
things uh it's not discrete in the
classical sense it's not like the
the um the lattice thing when you do
lattice qcd you you take a lattice and
you say okay this is discreteness is
there is fixed
this is in the quantum sense namely you
can have quantum superposition
of different discrete space time
right uh in in the in in a harmonic
oscillator you have discrete
eigenstate of the energy but the generic
quantum state is not any one of these
it's an arbitrary quantum superposition
of this
so the quantum states of loop quantum
gravity are quantum superposition
arbitrary quantum superposition of these
discrete things
that's the true picture so it's deeply
quantum mechanical
and one has to stop at space in the
classical sense
one has to think at this quantum state
of things
of course in the classical limit when
you disregard the
quantum gravity effect you go back to
classical general relativity and you get
space-time it's like photons photons
we know photons we're used to when you
go to the classical limit of describing
many many photons there's just a
smooth electromagnetic wave on the yeah
on
on a large scale so the same here the
the newtonian space of the einstein
space
with curves and bends is just the
approximate description
of uh at large scale of
particular semi-classical quantum states
which are in reality seen in the small
the quantum superposition of this
quantum space
and so would you say this is going to
write when
when i think about it and and you have
this owed even in
even in the order of time to um to john
wheeler
but it also i wonder who would you
rather talk to and explain
the current status of loop quantum
gravity to
uh feynman or wheeler and and keeping in
mind they were both heavily i mean
wheeler was feynman's teacher was he not
i wish i could talk with either of them
i talked to i talked to wheeler a lot
willa we i had a marvelous for me
of course relation with john wheeler i
mean he he wrote he read my
my first papers on loop quantum gravity
he was enormously excited he he wrote
well he was
excited about everything with his
personality um but he wrote to me
marvelous letters
i have in my you know i i adore him in
in my office there is a
um in marseille there is a copy of his
there is his letter on the wall i
i put it and i i went visit uh him in
fact you know i'm
i'm a relative but i didn't i did not
study on his book
the big bible generativity so no i did
not i studied on on
bob walden weinberg
and so on many other books uh but not
his and and when i went to princeton he
invited me to princeton to give him one
of my first talks on
gravity and i went there with my little
models of discreet space time
done with keyrings attached to one
another because i wanted to show
a three-dimensional thing which is
discrete in the small but you can
and he was excited like like a baby
and and he ran and took his book and
opened the page of his book in which he
has all the key rings attached to one
another
in in a picture for quantum space time
he loved the the early
um the early stage of of lukewarm
gravity i mean
he was old at that time but was very
enthusiastic
and then i discussed of course he had an
immense influence
on me on quantum mechanics also because
the relational quantum mechanics we're
going to talk about relational quantum
exactly next time
when algol come out but it was deeply
deeply influenced by
it from beating information will have
ideas
so if i could go back to joe wheeler
and tell him how much has um
loop quantum gravity evolved look on the
web is entirely based on his will of
intuition
i mean the the the form uh the
i i think he was a deep thinker um and
and he has opened a path
for for thinking on which i and my
colleagues have
have walked yeah and my last meeting
with him he was very old
and and uh i i mean i visited princeton
and we
were walking in the outside in the
countryside together he was talking to
me he was very frail and talking very
low voice and i'm a little bit deaf so i
didn't understand what he was saying i i
i couldn't say every two weeks
please talk higher louder uh so i missed
several of the things but but it was
still great yeah no he was uh famous for
so many things and so influential on
so much of physics it's it's it's
surprising to me that he's not
as well known as as he should be but um
but of course
uh that's a game of psychology and
politics but
but of course if i talk with simon would
be fantastic i mean hyman invented all
the firemen that's right
theory and spin form it's pure
phenomenology
uh it's terminology right it's it's a
it's computing transition amplitude by
by by it's all graphs it's two complexes
because they're not particle moving in
space it's it's a it's a quantum
space uh evolving your summing of
revolution of quantum space that's what
spin form is
and the difference is that the quantum
space um are connected
so they're not described by points
they're described by graph
so when you evolve a graph uh you get it
too complex
so the point the node of the graph the
quantum space the lines
but then the links um span surfaces so
you have a sort of bubbly thing
this is the the the the the spin form
picture the form
comes from this bubbling thing that you
get when you revolve the links
and and and so the space the the
you have to think about space time from
from some quantum state of space another
quantum space
state of space as a summing of a form
in between which you can think at the
same time
as a phenomenology of the
of the quantum space and the connection
moving or
as we reform it's the same thing you
will form
right so things come together in in the
intuition
and the beauty of that is you do quantum
mechanics not in space-time
right but of space-time in a way
which is finite in the ultraviolet so
this is the beauty of blue quantum
reality
i mean science is step by step one by
one okay we know this we know this maybe
let's make a little step and it's gonna
work
this is the way it works in my opinion i
think the universe is made by
by the real staff that interact these
interactions are real
um so if you ask me are the quant of
space predicted by loop quantum gravity
real i think yes
they are this is a good way of thinking
about the universe these are little
chunks of space i mean assuming that the
theory is right you see he's wrong
they're right in the same s they're real
the same sense in which atoms are real
okay even if we don't see them but then
we have a very good intuition
of atoms and molecules the powerful way
of
making concrete this is realism to that
realism is develop appropriate intuition
for what's there
and using it for grasping the reality
which of course is outside our mind
yeah i'm trying uh uh to get gerard
hoofed to come on uh because he has some
uh
recent speculations in this in this
field about you know
can quantum mechanics be manifestly
simulated in other words can you
on an ordinary um you know classical
computer made of silicon
you know can not exotic super conducting
materials such as those we use in our
lab
uh qubits etc but can you actually
simulate it and if you can't
you know does that have some
implications as to the veracity of
whether or not
it's possible to ontologically speak
about you know what is a model of
quantum mechanics so anyway i'm hoping
to have him on
but um but one of the questions i get
you know quite frequently
with you know garrett lisey or
queinstein you know these these kind of
multiple divergent and i had stephen
wolferman
you know he's sort of the most you know
clearly i guess what einstein uses you
know marble
and wood or you know whatever there are
these different concepts of theories and
physics
you know i classify stephen wolfe from
the cellular automata it's kind of like
wood it's a construction it's it's
something physical whereas marble is
is this pure form that god uses to make
sculptures or whatever
um and the question of you know like why
do is there only a theory of everything
is there only
one theory of everything and i know
you've talked about this like
luke quantography is not a theory of
everything for what does that even mean
but it seems to me that luke quantum
gravity might have a better ability and
i'll tell you what i mean in this sense
i'm not flattering you
you know you know me better than that no
please do flatter me i'm happy
okay yeah that's uh yeah i have to
flatter you know i have to flatter
somebody in the hopes vainly that
someone will flatter me someday but
um stephen wolfram you know i asked him
on the show i said do you get
you know bell's inequality do you get
the epr paradigm like it's not a theory
of everything
in the sense that it's not going to
predict all phenomena but it may have
something to say about you know he
claims it
makes testable predictions about black
hole you know collisions that can
propagate at a certain speed
etc so you said you're not particularly
as
interested in theories of everything but
it does seem to me and maybe it's maybe
it's not true but
in limp quantum gravity wouldn't things
like epr
and so forth emerge in a sense in other
words isn't that built into the fabric
of your version of emergent space time
oh yeah absolutely i mean look um
look on the right is conservative it's
genuine quantum mechanics it's not
trying to replace quantum mechanics with
something
else so you have entanglement obviously
of entanglement you have long distance
entanglements
your vpr uh you have all general
relativity stuff because you have the
classical limit which generativity
that's one
some theorems that do that so um
let's distinguish a theory like
um a loop quantum gravity which
builds on quantum mechanics and builds
on generativity and and has just
is a quantum mechanical theory
appropriately adapted for generativity
so times comes in the proper weight and
so on and so forth but it's
standard quantum mechanics um let's
distinguish this
from wild speculations like
oh behind quantum mechanics there is a
classical um uh
story like tough ones like wolfen
wants like other people want um
i mean i i all my wishes
for them to succeed but there are very
strong theorems
uh that say that it's impossible to have
a local hidden variable theory
um so you can do a non-local hidden
variable series so you can you can do
a classical um
theory that reproduces the same
prediction quantum mechanics
but it's going to be even more wild than
what you started from because it has
things happening here affecting really
classically something happening
um there in in in an extremely
uh uh funny way it has to break
lawrencium variants so
you you want to go back to a classical
metaphysics but the price to pay
is to deny everything we've learned
about the world with classical mechanics
like florence variance
i mean why would you do that i think you
have to adapt
your metaphysics or your intuition to
what you've learned with physics and not
the other way around
it's a little bit like uh uh uh
when they all look like me like tico
bright you want me take a bry
when copernicus came out with his story
one of the
difficult things to digest that
everything goes around the sun
is that the earth moves right i mean
there's in
in copernicus model the earth moves like
crazy i mean we are going
crazy speed around the rotate and also
around the sun both
so bry was the the the great
experimentalist who
they called this astronomical
measurement and then hired kepler and
which was not a bad idea
um he came out with his own model
antico model is the third one is neither
copernicus nor ptolemies it's thicker
model
and the earth is not moving and then
around the earth goes the sun and
everything goes around the sun
right so it's an attempt to save the
copernic
advantage of the copernical revolution
but not moving the
the earth it was completely misleading
right this is a silly idea why was it
still idea
because it was trying to conserve an
intuition a pre-copernical evolution
intuition
not willing to give it up so there's a
lot
of physicists that try to save
a pre-quantum mechanical intuition
instead of just give up believe quantum
theory the world is not i mean one of my
titles my books is reality is not what
it looks like
really is not the way we used to think i
mean simultaneity is not well-defined
things are not classical they're
generally quantum we have to understand
quantum mechanics but in its own terms
not by reducing it to um to classicality
and this is also the in a different
direction the quarrel i have
which people who have to people who take
the the wave function the quantum state
too seriously they want to
interpret the state um as if it was a
thing a classical field
maybe in hilbert space sean carroll was
one of that many world people
leonard now you know hawking's fine yes
i think it's a mistake i mean the the
quantum state is like the hamilton
jacobi equation
is is like a hemita jacobi function in
fact it's the hemp of a coin function is
a limit
of the glycemic classical limit quantum
state so that's what it is
and the hamilton jacobi function is just
a tool
for computing where we're going to find
the particle
but it's not the thing the thing is a
particle that's right and quantum
mechanics is about
things and these things i think is an
interaction that's my
deep understanding of quantum mechanics
quantum mechanics tells you
how things interacting with one another
it's about the relation between things
and things have property when they
interact
um and and and in loop quantum gravity
this applies to space itself
so space is uh it's it's a gravitational
field
it's a stuff it's a bunch of stuff that
interact with something else because
this
pen interacts with all the quantum space
around
and so theory tell us how the quantum
space act on the pen and how the pen act
on the
on the quanta of space and how all these
things move together
and that's the story of the world this
happening
relative happening of things well
described by equations that we can write
down which of course probabilistic
equations
you know when i think about that i i
think about what can i test you know
because one of the poetic things about
your book
um the order of time is uh is how
longing you talk about the taste of a
madeline you talk about
you know the sipping of wine and and
good friends and good company etc
and it's it's it's longing and and i
started off the conversation talking
about you know well time is the most
um is the most irretrievable asset
everybody says that i actually don't
believe that i
i think innocence is the most perishable
of all qualities because innocence is
time-bound
you know i've got a bunch of young kids
i'm blessed to have them and i look at
them and i'm like i want to preserve
their innocence as long as possible
because it's like a ratchet and paul it
never goes backwards and
and once you're exposed to something
maybe good maybe bad
you can never really get back from that
you know what john willow used to say
what's that never run after
a woman a bus or a theory of everything
because don't worry there will be always
another one coming after a while
well one of my one of my friends is a is
a cowboy or cowgirl and she says
you know cow droppings are like men the
older they are the easier they are to
get rid of
so you know some of these things are uh
perishable in a certain sense but
uh before we get to the final questions
that i ask everybody on these um
i want to talk about a project that i'm
interested in which is uh
modeled after galileo galilei and that
i'm calling it
il sagittori or the the assayer you know
galileo's one of his little known books
but to me it's
it's another example of his genius of
his brilliance and of his humanity that
he was
you know subjected to confirmation bias
as much as any other physicist in the
world but he also
despite that had so many great um great
conjectures about the nature of reality
and that was uh that comets were a
phenomenon
in the earth's atmosphere that was what
he believed and it's really one of the
only
blunders that he made besides the fact
that the earth's tides are caused by the
moon
are sorry by the earth's motion instead
of by the moon he desperately wanted to
prove
copernicus and and others well that's
blunder that you're referring to
it's in fact i mean if you read the
dialogue
carefully scientifically it's totally
wrong yes yes it is because that's a
yeah so that's the the entire dialogue
hinges
on this argument right you know that you
know what
if you call it by the way carla do you
remember do you know what the original
title of the book was
the original title that galileo chose
was on the flux and reflux
of the earth's tides which as you just
pointed out is completely incorrect it
has nothing to do with that it's
completely correct so the entire point
he
he wants to prove the copernicus system
by arguing that since the the the earth
goes around the sun and rotating itself
the the the the the oceans uh
are in a sort of non-inertial movement
that creates the tides
and if you think for a moment that this
means
not understanding galilean invariants
yeah
which is his greatest contribution
relativity right
but exactly but the other thing that's
kind of that makes me want to pursue
this project
and and the the project is basically
look at existing data
and see if you can get um uh information
about
uh uh unification of forces rather than
saying
you have to propose a new experiment
that could cost 20 billion dollars in
other words look at past experiment and
i give the following example
uh one of one of galileo's observations
which he did make
was on the procession of sunspots which
mario olivio who you might
probably know very well he claims that
galileo that that's the best evidence
for the uh for the uh revolution of the
earth around the sun
is the uh the appearance of those but it
was he didn't
interpret them right or he didn't
emphasize them enough but my point is
not whether he was right or wrong that's
a matter of a matter of history and
science and historians of science can
speculate on
but what i want to say is that that data
existed
at his time and he could have used it to
prove
his theory better than the theory of the
tides which was completely wrong
i'm asking you you know is it possible
that there are data
that are out there that we can use
already to confirm or refute because
you're a good scientist
the uh the the veracity of
loop quantum gravity or maybe even of
string theory i mean you might already
say that string theory is not only
refutable or falsifiable
as other people have come on the podcast
have said it's been falsified
so you know are there other examples of
low energy limits
um take hurts you know hertz could you
know prove the you know
electromagnetic waves which later would
be you know the foundation of quantum
mechanical waves and matter waves as
well so
uh and gravitational waves yeah let me
yeah i'm going to answer it let me first
just correct because then
um people are going to quote you um i i
i don't want to say that strength is
falsified no i don't think it's possible
no no it's it could still be true i
think that uh
science doesn't go falsification i mean
all speculations are not falsified but
they all can be true
what happens is that you pile up sort of
bayesian confirmation of this
confirmation
that make things more plausible and less
plausible so for instance
the non-discovery of supersymmetry at
cern
is a heavy disconfirmation technically
in the bayesian sense
of supersymmetry and therefore string
theory namely
if we had found supersymmetry
um the people doing string theory would
have said you see i am
real on the wrong track it doesn't glue
it right but
it it it's it's in the right direction
it it weights in our direction the fact
of
for this very same reason in in the
bayesian logic of of giving
credibility to things the fact of not
having found something when everybody
was
when most people were expecting it
lowers the confidence level that's why
many people moved away from you know
sort of taking
uh supersymmetry a string theory it's a
plausible um
hypothesis about the real structure of
nature uh
after the non-discovery supersymmetry so
i would not use falsification i would
use d
they confirm uh this confirmation
invasion no i think
but let me come to your to your question
because your question is very good of
course
it's ordinary good and and and um
i wish i i mean the answer is obviously
i i
certainly is possible of course it's
possible but where
i don't know i wish i could find
something
of that sort i mean with my students in
in marseilles and postdocs and
colleagues we often have
just trying to brainstorm and one thing
we have done for instance is that
think at all the experiments uh
uh that gave indication about quantum
mechanics in in in the
early of last century right
there were so many i mean is there
anything similar about quantum gravity
something
interference phenomena or something we
can read in in in the immense amount of
data we have about the universe that
could be a hint of that
we've been searching here and there
interference is a key that we were
um i i don't know any if i knew i would
immediately write a paper to nature and
say look look let's look there or i'll
call you and say yeah exactly right
yeah i pointed like let's do that that
was fun to collaborate but uh
yeah don't give up because you know it's
true that we actually discovered or
mckellar has claimed to discover
the cmb in 1944 from the observation of
certain transitions in cyanogen gas
and that was 20 years before the
discovery by pennsylvan wilson of the
cmb so this happens
and there can be data and actually yeah
and the the
the the big black hole of sagittarius
was there were data about it
since and galileo discovered neptune
but he didn't realize that that was what
he was seeing he thought it was oh i
didn't know
i didn't know that he had very much i
didn't
i always say it's too bad because he
could have had a good career um
okay you know einstein used mercury
used mercury anomaly
uh which of course was in the data
before yes i mean he just
found a way to retro and uh and he got
it from poincare poincare noticed
that i'm writing a small introductory
book
uh textbook on general activity on the
course that i gave in generativity and
in fact i realized that
for mercury is just it's pretty obvious
i mean if you if you
i understand how powerful i got it if
you take just the the data of mercury
the
the orbital period and you fold it uh
uh see see the speed of light c-square
uh and you get a a a dimensional
number this number is exactly of the
order of of of magnitude
of of the of the anomaly in in the
procession
so a posteriori i mean why
it was obvious that it's a relativistic
effect
it's a c-square effect you just need it
in a number right so it's a relativistic
effect obviously there's a sort of
magnetic effect of the gravitational
field
so it's the right thing to test
relativistic theory of gravity
interesting yeah when i think about
galileo and einstein first of all
einstein wrote the forward to this
edition the the this book
and he calls it one of the greatest
books of popular science writing
uh of course it is so i'm hoping to get
you involved to read just the forward by
galileo
where he i wish i i i'd be
humbled and honored of doing so okay
it's one of my life's goals i will talk
to you about that after the show okay
for now
we're gonna finish up because i you know
carla when i became an astronomer i
thought i'd be on using telescopes all
the time but i really use telecons all
the time i'm always on telecons
i got one in five minutes i want to
finish up if you'll indulge me with
questions i ask all of my guests
ranging from eight nobel prize winners
soon to be nine
uh all the way up to um you know the
humblest of all people that
i am humbled to have on my show i i'm so
grateful
that people like you come on and i call
these the into the impossible
thrilling three questions and to hear
them uh you have to subscribe to my
mailing list because that and i will
send them to carlow but for those of you
who have not signed up for my mailing
list at brianketing.com please do so
you'll get
life tips from jim simons the world's
smartest billionaire you'll get frank
wilcex
uh questions you get avi loeb you may
have noticed uh carlo avi loeb has a new
book out
which we'll talk about uh some other
time perhaps about an external
extraterrestrial intelligence that
visited us anyway if you want to hear
carlo's answers please subscribe to my
newsletter
and i will send them to you the
thrilling three and these
involve in one sense or another time
which carlo is the
uh foremost exponent proponent and
uh and and really just such a lovely
book uh carlo i know you don't need to
hear it
uh but uh but or you don't need to my
opinion about it my encomium on it but
it is
it was a very touching book and i was
listening to at the very end of it with
my nine-year-old in the car
and he was talking about wow this that's
like why
is this a physics book data cause he
hears me listen to you know physics
books all the time and
has a lot more uh fewer equations than
those ones carlo
thank you so much for going into the
impossible with me i hope we can get
together
in person maybe here on the sunny
southern california beaches
and i wish you all the best and until
your next book eggolan comes out
in a few months we'll have you back on
brian it was great talking to you thank
you very much for having me
my pleasure
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
you